when I started running the Bitcoin
energy consumption index back in 2017
Bitcoin has joked that the Network's
energy consumption only represented the
annual amount of electricity consumed by
Christmas light in the U.S now four
years later this has this amount has
gone up more than 20 fold putting the
energy consumption of the Bitcoin
Network on par with the electrical
energy consumption of a country like
Argentina and at the current price the
network could soon consume as much
energy as all data centers around the
world combine so that includes all data
centers we use for traditional Finance
social media cloud service the internet
itself it will represent one percent of
our total Global electricity consumption
all this energy is being spent on a
process known as mining in order to
create new blocks of transactions for
Bitcoins underlying blockchain Bitcoin
miners have to participate in what is
effectively a massive game of guess the
number only those who guess correctly
are allowed to create block for the
blockchain and we'll be given a reward
for doing so the whole Bitcoin Network
currently generates more than 140
quintillion that's 140 with 18 zeros of
such guesses every second of the day
non-stop even so a new block will only
be created every 10 minutes on average
if the computational power in the
network increases the software just
makes it more difficult to guess the
right number which keeps the issuance
rate steady incorrect guesses which
means almost all of them should have no
further purpose than requiring potential
attackers of the network to make an even
more of those useless computations than
the ones currently doing so if they want
to do harm to the network
as Bitcoin miners get paid a fixed
amount of Bitcoin for every block they
create their ultimate income strongly
depends on the Bitcoin price that means
that as the Bitcoin price goes up the
profitability of mining increases as
well and that also increases the
incentive to run more energy hungry
machines we have seen the Bitcoin price
hitting new all-time highs earlier this
year and that's why the energy
consumption of the network is now also
higher than ever before now this energy
consumption has multiple consequences
and the most obvious one is that
generating the electricity that's used
by the network produces emissions and
the majority of this energy has always
originated from burning fossil fuels and
because of this the emissions associated
with Bitcoin mining are now more than
negating the entire amount of net CO2
savings from deploying electric vehicles
all around the world and if you were to
look at Bitcoin and ethereum combined
that ethereum being the second largest
cryptocurrency then the total emissions
would even amount around to 100 million
metric tons of CO2 per year
that's twice the internet CO2 savings as
a result of deploying electric vehicles
it's also 0.3 percent of our total
Global CO2 emissions as calculated by
the International Energy agency and if
the current Global chip shortage wasn't
holding back the growth of the network
we would be talking more in a range of
half a percent of our Global emissions
at the current price levels but as long
as prices remain where they are today we
will probably get to that point soon
enough
Bitcoin miners just love fossil fuels so
much that China recently completely
banned Bitcoin mining as Idle coal mines
were being revived for the purpose of
mining bitcoins and in this case that
also happened illegally directly leading
to a loss of human lives as these
operations lack proper safety
precautions in the U.S Bitcoin miners
were responsible for Reviving an old
natural gas plant in New York for the
purpose of mining bitcoins in Montana
they closed the deal with a coal plan
that was scheduled to be closed and in
Pennsylvania miners even started burning
waste call which is a lot worse than
burning regular coal in terms of
emissions
additionally a large chunk of the miners
that were sent away from China appear to
have found a new home in Alberta Canada
a third of the entire Bitcoin Network
may actually be moving there to take
advantage of leftover natural gas
capacity so that means that the network
isn't turning Greener as components of
the digital currency argue and the need
for both cheap and stable power sources
increase basically drives miners towards
Obsolete and Stranded fossil fuel
sources
now the fact that these miners are all
looking for the same cheap sources also
drives them to the same location and
that adds yet another consequence to the
energy consumption as it can lead to a
local grid becoming overwhelmed you've
seen power outages in country like Iran
and Acacia as a result of the influx of
Bitcoin miners so people are literally
left in the dark because of Bitcoin
mining and the consequences don't even
stop there in particular Bitcoin mining
nowadays requires highly specialized
equipment to be competitive that's
typically short-lived equipment that
cannot be repurposed at all so the
electronic waste that's ultimately
produced by the network at yet another
layer on top of the sustainability
issues of the network which is something
that no amount of renewable energy could
ever address now while tackling all
these issues will not solve climate
change up to half a percent of our
Global emissions is obviously far from
an insignificant amount especially at
the time when every ton of CO2 matters
and it also shouldn't be hard to see how
this can rapidly spiral further out of
control the hand the data centers of the
traditional financial sector handle more
than 700 billion electronic payments a
year Bitcoin right now handles about
0.02 percent of that volume while the
energy costs already exceeds the former
so one can only really fear what happens
if Bitcoin gets more mainstream adoption
because that will surely drive up the
Bitcoin price and its environmental
impact
sounds like you're just about to come to
a ringing close there Alex are you happy
on that closing point I was just about
to point out six minutes but you were
ahead of me brilliantly trained
participants in these things your body
clock it's not your your digital cook uh
got you out in six minutes thank you
very much indeed and of course you'll
have time to complete some of those
thoughts and and reply to Lynn who is
going to now take over the floor for me
and Lynn Alden financial analyst founder
of Lynn else an investment strategy she
provides tens of thousands of investors
with the latest research information and
tools to help them build wealth and
manage their digital assets one of the
world's best-known Bitcoin Advocates her
work is featured in The Wall Street
Journal Business Insider CNBC and much
more but Lynn tonight the Intelligence
Squared crowd is your audience six
minutes to convince them
all right thanks for having me
um and so when we talk about Bitcoin the
first thing is to point out that you
know it does have benefits for the world
and so it's you know a lot of us kind of
come at this from kind of a privileged
developed Market perspective when we
look if we take a step back we look
globally why was it created what is it
what is its purpose and so the first
thing is the fact that you know roughly
half the world's population lives in
some sort of authoritarianism according
to Freedom House and also if you look at
you know the vast majority of Emerging
Markets well over a billion people most
of them have experienced either
hyperinflation or very very high levels
of double-digit inflation uh sometime in
their lifetimes uh and so there is a
very strong need for basically you know
some sort of currency that is stateless
that is permissionless that can be sent
without you know a centralized third
party being able to block those
transactions and to have basically some
degree of scarcity with that currency uh
and so that's that's why we've had you
know 12 years now of rising popularity
estimates shows that over 100 million
people world have used Bitcoin and that
number continues to grow over time uh
and so that that naturally brings
concerns about you know it's is proof of
work out there because Bitcoin uses
proof of work the reason it does that
complicated process is because that's
what keeps it decentralized basically
work is what what verifies the
blockchain rather than any centralized
third party
and so Bitcoin is not designed on the
base layer to be a rapid transaction
Network although additional layers on
top of it like lightning liquid or
custodial transactions built on top of
that base layer can radically expand and
are rapidly expanding its transaction
throughput but the main purpose is that
decentralized savings and permissionless
Payments Technology now when we talk
about the scale uh you know Bitcoin as
you know we've seen a number of students
excited already but you know the
University of Cambridge estimates that
Bitcoin uses about 0.1 percent or less
of global energy production and so but
the concern is what if that scales up uh
and in my view it will scale up and
that'll be a good thing but when we you
know it's important to understand the
details of how that scaling algorithm
works because every time a new block is
mined uh you know as as previously
pointed out miners receive a certain
number of Bitcoin but every four years
that number of Bitcoin they they earn
goes down it's called the declining
block subsidy and so that's why Bitcoin
minor revenue does not scale as quickly
as the market capitalization and so for
example back in 2012 when the protocol
is pretty new minor Revenue accounted
for about 27 percent of Bitcoin market
capitalization by 2015 that was down to
about nine percent uh by 2018 that was
down to about four percent and in the
first half of this year it was down to
1.9 percent and over time you know after
about a decade that starts to approach
only transaction fees there's you know
virtually all the Bitcoin or mined and
so miners rely on transaction fees which
so far have been a small fraction of one
percent of Bitcoin market capitalization
every year
and so basically it becomes more and
more energy efficient every year as the
initial 21 million coins are distributed
and the system uh shifts towards
transactions and so it's important to
understand that long-term scaling uh
rather than just you know the simplistic
method of taking market capitalization
extrapolating it linearly exponentially
which I see a lot of journalists and
economics uh people doing
um and so you know lastly a key thing to
focus on is how Bitcoin uses energy so
Bitcoin is a buyer of Last Resort
because it has two very specific
qualities one is that uh it can go into
remote locations uh because it does not
require high bandwidth or high personnel
and that's so it's unlike a data center
it's unlike some sort of manufacturing
facility it can go out to remote
locations it can even co-locate inside
of nuclear plants
geothermal plants hydroelectric dams
solar farms uh stranded natural gas it
can go out to these locations and the
second you know feature of it is they
can it can withstand periods of being
turned off because it's not like a data
center any one Bitcoin miner can
fluctuate as long as it it takes that
into account in terms of its contract
pricing and it's what we see generally
is that Bitcoin miners especially as the
markets become more mature more
efficient
has shifted more and more towards these
agreements to take up excess Supply and
so the way our grid works and again this
is something a lot of journalists and
economists Miss is that we have to
produce more energy than we consume uh
otherwise you know turning on the
marginal laptop would cause brownouts
right so we have to have more more
production than we have consumption
because we need that buffer but a lot of
renewable sources uh are are variable or
always on like solar wind geothermal
Hydro nuclear and these naturally have
these periods where they're producing
more than the the Grid in hundreds of
miles can take at that current time and
so what we're starting to see more and
more is that Bitcoin miners are
co-locating and being able to basically
absorb that excess Supply so when we
calculate how much Bitcoin uh uh you
know energy Bitcoin uses that's largely
non-rival energy that's you know buyer
of Last Resort energy to go into places
where it's stranded and even an example
earlier was stranded natural gas and so
according to Cambridge uh you know the
world's stranded natural gas could power
the current bitcoin Network almost eight
times over
and what that means is these remote
sites where they're getting hydrocarbons
and they produce a little bit of gas in
the side but it's not economical enough
to build a pipeline or take it and so
they literally burn it into the
atmosphere so Bitcoin miners go out and
say okay you're going to burn it anyway
so sell to us for a very low cost and we
will we will mine Bitcoin with it and so
I think you're going to increasingly see
those sorts of things and I'm actually
excited for that because that can really
incentivize renewable energy and so at
the current extrapolation even if
Bitcoin is 10 times bigger than it is
now because the declining block subsidy
its energies which will not be 10 times
larger and then even when it was even if
it does get to that point it's actually
a very you know important aspect to the
grid this is a new type of energy buyer
which I think is going to actually
unlock a lot of renewable energy that's
available in the world